oh
he did not expect that that was awesome
citizens of the reject Nation how are
you on this fine day it is time to dive
back in to the DC Animated Universe with
Son of Batman how you doing John I am
great to do you know what just let me
say I I've been looking forward to the
next time you've been away and we
haven't shot one of these in a minute
yeah and when Greg came up with this
idea to put us together I was already
super excited and now this is like one
of my favorite only all-time things to
do on the channel it's the best like
thank you so also thank you okay
sex reject nation and for you guys for
for being so responsive this is such a
blast yeah if you guys didn't comment
like And subscribe which I would
encourage you to do to comment like And
subscribe we couldn't do it because it
wouldn't grow because YouTube algorithms
so do comment like subscribe so we can
keep doing these because this shirt says
sons of the Batman if we watch enough of
these maybe this movie will be called
that retroactively by having more Sons
because there's many Robins I assume
that's the plot we haven't seen this you
haven't seen this I haven't seen this at
all and remember if you want to watch
this all the way through the syncing up
one to one start to finish all the way
through do become a patron that way you
can join us for the entire Journey all
the little beats all the little moments
want to know what our resting faces look
like be a patron want to know what
things got cut be a patriot want to know
if we swear more we do be a patron I
actually don't know what the plot of
this one is because I knew a bit about
Flashpoint having read the comic I knew
kind of what war had to be I have no
idea what the implication is here so
we're about to find out together our
very first watch of Son of Batman let's
do it
[Music]
PG-13 intrigues me oh I missed that logo
that's beautiful
I missed that logo yeah oh little
Batman's in it though a little surprise
that is cool I'm a sucker for the 90s
Circle DC myself I feel you
Kyle Rainer era Superboy era
[Music]
the business to defeat the Huns
I'm Gonna Make a Man Out of all these
guys here is your inheritance the League
of Assassins they will be yours to
command to make certain the Earth abides
a natural contentment that's John Carlo
I think it is
it is good to see our revered father so
devoted to his grandson
yes brother it is
take the boys dang
[Music]
my bad that's why is
Al ghoul we're gonna find out how they
pronounced it place your bets Choose
Your Own Adventure
foreign
I like the use of mirroring animation
for how well-trained the soldiers are
because it works twice yeah
they all brought a bunch of knives to a
gunfight come on now and a helicopter
helicopter fight
sweet
good shot
that's Selena right
[Laughter]
should calum's just hanging out with uh
not her dad
Italia
[Music]
oh
damn kid trained you well
oh nice rock beats helicopter
a league of silhouettes
[Music]
was that a Wilhelm scream
it was very close sound kind of like a
Wilhelm scream he's mine
confused old man
slain oh
[Music]
how could you have pushed me out I was
your right hand oh interesting
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
500 years the world's had quite enough
of you old man
the Lazarus Pit will not bring you back
this time
we'll see about that
[Music]
oh let's see what the Son of Batman can
do oh
dang
it's still 80 pounds
[Music]
cool I'll make you suffer for this boy
next time
you guys are gonna have to modernize
your game
I mean they got an arrow Gatling gun
frankly what else do you do that's
clearly they won
too cooler
oh the bottle of Xanax
we have to get him into the Lazarus Pit
somebody help him out 27.
damn stop we have to try we can't just
leave him he's dead this is what the
Lazarus Pit is for some continuities it
can't depends on who's writing we we
have to move come where are we going
Gotham City
time to meet your father
[Music]
alimony payments are over you
Waylon Jones AKA Killer Croc stealing
drugs isn't your usual Mo
but Exposition is
when half the biotech firms in town get
hit I get curious
you look like you've been working out
Croc
is he ever not
it's a pretty big guy
oh bummer
[Music]
yes the bat forklift
never leave home without it
that's Jason O'Mara Batman back is it I
was trying to place it I think you're
right I think so
stop fighting in the Indiana Jones
Warehouse
with your bare fists against the Killer
Croc
the problem with steroids is I'll get
the munchies
[Laughter]
[Music]
you should have warned your playdate
I'm the only one who can bite you
shocked to see me it's not the Arnold Mr
Freeze movie that'd be a different
electrifying entrance though yeah their
chemistry really is electric
you remember our shared moonlight
some of it
the best parts conceiving our son he
doesn't know he's gonna find out the
weirdest way assassins plan to take over
racist organization they are led by a
man who father believed could be his
successor now this man wants to kill us
us me
and your son son what did you say that
day
you expect me to believe this I assure
you he's yours we asked Maury it looks
just like both of us look at him
well I guess I'll watch the kid she
thinks she'll be better off with me what
do you think better than with the League
of Assassins they taught me how to fight
I take it not much else
I'll teach you how to drive yeah you
become a man today
I like that Batmobile yeah it's pretty
sweet good thing I brought the
two-seater sweet
great looking Gotham too yeah I like the
art deco as much as they can bring it
back Mom said leave your test tubes and
come now she has dinner I'm close to a
breakthrough
you're always close to a breakthrough
I'm doing it for us
oh making something turn blue in a tube
my meth is the best meth
perhaps I could use a bite
I'm starting to see double here
wait up
injured well the rest of the servants
I am the sum total you have only one
servant he's not a servant
he's a friend
hear that Alfred yeah heartwarming kind
he is the spitting image of you at that
age you're gonna have to get him settled
I'm not sure how long he'll be here but
for the time being this will be his home
he just left like I just took off on a
boat prepare some tea pennyworth brown
sugar instead of whites fresh cut lemon
a China cup perhaps Master would like
some warm mixed nuts and a moist hand
towel
I'm not so young that I don't understand
sarcasm
well I am much too old to care yeah I
just want them to fight
yeah the whole set of Batman to Damian
I miss him already
I'm proceeding according to plan ah you
seem to think I'm part of the old
agreement
I am not from this point on I will be
arranging separate accommodations for
your family ew
in Hell
Rachel ghoul has been retired
I am his successor
you will call me Deathstroke Deathstroke
this is a pretty cool mask pull I like
the little chin strap harness to keep it
tucked
he's been at it since five o'clock this
morning
I hope you don't mind sir the sword is
your grandfather's the one on the wall
plaque
too you should get a job as a gardener
only so many bushes yeah what's the rest
of the yard look like yeah when he's
gonna start beheading these topiaries
wait for his dad to show up
not the giraffe it took months to grow
then
what the hell
the profit margin is down in Argentina
someone is skimming Revenue
that's my division Bruce it's okay it's
all right I'll deal with this
what are you doing
reviewing my Birthright
Deathstroke killed my grandfather he has
to pay race was a Madman he was a hero
he died a hero
's Deathstroke's right-hand man he used
to work my grandfather he stays in
Gotham City between missions to indulge
his vices
you downloaded this from the computer in
the Batcave didn't you I hacked into
NORAD when I was six it was easy
wait
I like that he got his little turtleneck
and slacks where to get those little
clothes
man he made them no stops you will not
go off on your own for any reason you
will stay away from the Batcave computer
and you will stay out of sight do you
understand I own my grandfather a
[Music]
not a yes young man nope not even close
Hogwarts looks nice this time of year
it's the crossover we need zatana and
Harry Potter let's do it justice league
dark
foreign
Deathstroke is mine
yes
he will be proclaimed this will go well
why are they all running like that anime
kid it's the most efficient way to run
it saves money on animation
[Laughter]
how you run
[Music]
oh cool way of showing speed that was
rad I like that
we
mean let's do it let's do it Arkham
Asylum could be anybody
they're like if we
Cameo I mean frankly what even doing we
at least have to show everyone's face or
silhouette you got the last fix you're
gonna get from langstrom where is he
screw you
[Applause]
they don't want to get too close
but I'm not afraid
you help me I'll help you I'll take you
to Lazarus Pit right now
clean off growing back you know I assume
I hope
nice
[Music]
cool nice oh no
we got a Man-Bat please tell me we have
a man band
this might just be bat bats but I got oh
maybe hope for bandbat
oh I think we got it oh
what gonna go we get Gorilla yeah whoa I
thought maybe Grodd but nope winged
gorilla
right in the ape nips
[Music]
[Applause]
oh damn
foreign
yeah I was gonna say he's fine giant
Wizard of Oz monkey just came out of
nowhere I did not expect that but a
curveball yeah the wicked witch is
behind all this oh that's the secret
check out rash she wanted that youthful
serum for herself yeah I'm just gonna
bathe in the Lazarus but
[Music]
it's using your noodle bats
still understand how water towers work
me neither because it's not like the
water like comes directly out of them
into the city like I just don't I don't
know what they do it's just for safe
keeping it's for fun
a big aquarium I hope there's no cameras
in here
and you're gonna have to keep this
window shut if you want me to take my
things off whoa dang
this ain't your grandpappy's Batman
I'm going to give you to the count of
three
one
nice
leave harlots
just trying to make a living man
sex work has worked Damien called him
harlots
dang serious
[Music]
where is Deathstroke did you
that easy just ask and I would talk
I don't want it to be easy sure
oh yeah
let's go buddy
you're running from a child I know I
mean he just whooped you but still can't
feel good about yourself in this moment
no he's embarrassed
so damn
we do not vehicular manslaughter people
no Gotham safe drivers we do Frogger
though yes
crunchy
[Music]
you'll get nothing from me
either I get answers or you get the
sword
[Music]
oh no yeah
had to be
he did not expect that that was awesome
I heard you called my suit girly little
brother
talk missing something
whoa
says he's your son
Damien messed him up dude oh that was
clever that was really clever World
building quickly established both of
them yeah are you all right Master dick
I took the cut I can take the Stitch
maybe you need more anesthetic and maybe
you need to go faster
yes
ah the Neil gaming oh not Neil Gaiman
Neil um Adam suit that's cool
this was yours still is is this what you
were in training it's what I wore when I
went on patrol the only thing it's
missing is lace trim and a son
would be a good look I know what you're
thinking you're thinking you could be
Robin
well you can't
I don't need some insipid costume and a
bird name I'm Way Beyond your kind of
simplistic training as you saw tonight
don't forget
you lost that fight yeah you did how's
ubu it's got more monitors connected to
him than Arkham has fluid he takes
I'll stay in touch
he doesn't deserve to breathe
if it hadn't been for him if it hadn't
been for dick you'd have gone too far
it's easier my way it has nothing to do
with easy
it's about doing what's right because
it's right and that's the only reason
you need yeah heads up
good reflexes
what if I had missed
[Music]
it would have hurt
I want to help like he used to
it's bad enough you've given yourself
away and let them know we're on to them
but you're letting Vengeance guide your
actions you've never felt vengeful
every day let me tell you a kid
stay close that's an order
I can do that wait a minute I'm not
gonna like this
nope nope
yes
dang okay okay you let him have pants
that's good yes Robin pants how's ubu
doing we searched his place nothing much
there but we did find one interesting
item
it's a phone say a phone chat line
it's what's written on the other side
for a good time
what could have been dad used to bring
me here for ball games sometimes
afterward we go to the amusement park
and now history repeats itself
let's go
I don't need your amusing [__]
Batman
building respect
Dr langstrom
Deathstroke has my family where is
Deathstroke I don't know I'll make you
talk Robin no
he's just a scientist
no swords fine
you see you don't need it
hmm
oh yeah do the Black Widow yeah I'm no
coward don't be stupid
listen
oh no
the creatures
man bats all right we got him I'll take
it I'll take it
waiting for this day we got our man bats
plural I didn't expect plural yeah
it's a man Battalion
they're having a man battle they are
more Man-Bat puns
as for the patrons
okay now what
[Music]
oh yeah
yep yep yep always trust the tech he's
always ready with the tech where's
Victor Stone gonna play football now
where's Bane gonna have a speeches
oh Robin
[Music]
wanted me to splice animal DNA to human
using Advanced mutagens he wanted you to
make the ultimate warriors
yes
damn where's your family I don't know my
daughter mentioned something about snow
about two two mountain peaks that she
said look like cat ears
yep grandfather's compound you're
I'm sure
[Music]
going to Hogwarts let's go into Hogwarts
the owls have arrived
Damien's a Slytherin yeah it is
definitely a Slither
your romance with the Dark Knight wasn't
merely rumor who is he do it you must
I won't talk
I believe you
I was being crumbly Humanity like my
grandfather by killing if that's what it
took how do you hope to lead Humanity
when you've never been a part of it
your childhood wasn't a lot of fun
either I also had people around me to
help I had friends all you've had are
trainers there's a difference Damien
yeah you need people skills
[Music]
oh
nothing
[Music]
good parenting
listen
a false wall
oh nice
I want one yep
[Music]
please don't hurt us we're not here to
hurt you
Batman we've been so afraid you're all
right now Robin you saved us oh this is
totally unnecessary
to stroke said he would spare us if I
gave this to you
what
don't tell Batman oh no
oh no
this is between you and me leave the
sperm donor out of it wow wow
cheese dude I'll give you 48 hours
before I end her suffering
be worthy of your heritage boy
make your mother proud
John Wu directed that shot
imagine a John Woo superhero film would
be crazy he already doesn't believe in
physics it'd just be pure Madness
sword fighting motorcycles again a
dormant oil rig belonging to Race part
of a shell company went active a few
weeks back that is interesting hold on
Damien
yep
where's the oil rig Scotland off the
outer Hebrides what's wrong he's gone
and took his uniform Bruce chill the rig
is 50 miles off the coast what's he
gonna do swim there
big shell
and of course he swim
he's training yeah everything is
training
[Music]
well done little Solid Snake cardboard
box it up yeah
[Music]
stay on alert if so much as a seagull
tries to land on this rig shoot it mine
no
he knows you're following him he must he
has to be Deathstroke
is that a tribute to king shark just
then it has to be but you can't get him
it's a kid that's weird we didn't have
any kids
[Music]
foreign
bats just waiting I wouldn't make any
threatening moves
they'll stay put as long as I tell them
to the only thing this rig pumps is life
Everlasting
to the highest bidder
looks like your mother could use it
now this is what they call a standoff
not even the pit can bring back Mommy if
her head's blown off
your play Damien
I should congratulate you for getting
this far but that would be like
applauding a suit
ouch
so entitled so bloodthirsty so easy to
manipulate
I brought you here for one simple reason
to kill you
goodbye boy run Damien oh
selfless Act
foreign
boss
you're certainly not dead shot at this
Deathstroke nope
uh see what you did there
kill them
I'm bad at shooting yeah
I had one job to do
more of a sword man
yes yes smart
oh that's that's wow
[Music]
no
I'll end him I swear
[Music]
yeah that's what I'm afraid she's not
suggesting to you
foreign
nope
oh good
oh
this is not gonna be pumping life much
longer you're not you don't put stuff
underwater
yeah not especially if you're going to
have like a destructive bat Army
with little to no discretion
mindless in tubes
oh Nightwing save the day yeah yeah
[Music]
damn you're a quick study doc
who's that uh we're gonna drown they are
not saving them yep all right I hope
they can all swim
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing I'm not laughing at anything
it's tally always in like a cat suit
like this oh they literally leaned a
little aggressively on the every outfit
as boobs in it I'm not used to that it's
just end like the one time she was in
civilian clothes was the same yeah Talia
would have been mine as well until your
father came along
and created something special
ah Jesus
[Music]
out by the hilts just just went for it I
mean to survive I guess I feel that
[Music]
still swinging those swords though
he's got adrenaline he's just very thick
forearms
oh
[__] stroke
I know what that smells like like
absinthe it looks like ooh the Phoenix
Force
[Music]
cool nice
now
[Music]
your luck ends you call it luck I call
it skill
about it my one good eyes
I knew you would save us
I haven't yet
oh
Batman chose love the whole place is
collapsing
no
the Lazarus juice
last one saved from that absence of joy
oh nice cool
[Music]
his arms are just so toasty
he's gonna be in double casts
get that last Lazarus juice just dunk
your arms in it boy
[Music]
maybe it'll heal his eye
you were trained to kill your enemies
weren't you it's what you want
I would do
grandfather would do
but not what your dad would do I'm my
Father's son too
not bad get in
dang I guess this would have like an
escape rocket have to
the owl I'm not gonna save you either
that's not murder no
come on Kiera Nightwing
foreign
good old bat magnet suction cups never
leave the cave without them I thank you
for my life and the life of my son our
son I need to rebuild the league make it
stronger better
Harder Faster I'm gonna kill more
efficiently Damien should stay with me
he will want to be with his mother
he's Robin now he stays with the Batman
uh are you ready to come
if that's your wish mother learn from
your Father Damien
for he is very wise and you are the
future
you got this Damien
I will come back for him make him great
I will
shared custody if only people could
solve problems with more swords
[Music]
God what a beautiful sky just a couple
of Batman let's go home Damien
I'll drive no I know
oh good button right there I like that
yeah no it's a nice way to leave that
off
um
all right D Bradley Baker was all the
Mad bats Giancarlo hell yeah David
McCallum was Alfred cool casket right
all right we're in a back room with that
Comet cred I know Deadpool and this she
must be a comic book fan
I like that the robin Cape had that
little bit of like kind of like fur like
the black over the yellow or like yeah
or feathers yeah whatever that was I
like that look because you can't quite
discern that in the comics all the time
like he definitely has some like Fringe
accent yeah I liked that I like how it
moved yeah it was a cool design and they
gave him pants and pants they gave him
Robin pants I think we're gonna get a
decent amount of robins in the uh the
James Gunn take on Batman because it's
one of the few things they haven't
really done yet yeah and I've heard in
recent times some interesting please for
why we should have other people want the
Robin and and kind of how interesting
and and somewhat peculiar it is that so
many filmmakers have been so opposed
it's really hard to do right like it's
it's very easy to get Robin wrong uh you
know it's it's a ward uh it's like you
know something that lives in your house
it's just the the suit can be in this
handled the character give me this
handled and also it's really like a a a
deeper end of the story Batman Choice
than they've really done in a while
that's fair you need to really build
them up I think they're just going to
throw us into it this time though I
think we're gonna get about Batman
that's already pretty established I
think he's gonna have a bat family uh I
also think that it will be a way to
distinguish from the Batman Universe I
think that's a good idea yeah and like I
honestly think that you know I talked
about the duality of Batman I think
Flashpoint when I was saying how like
the villain can be opposite of Batman in
so many different ways was that flash
point
but like I think Robin represents
another antithesis a Batman of like was
it during Red Hood it was red hood
that's it yeah it seems like it would
make sense to be talking about that
shirt Batman was in Red Hood wasn't he
uh but I think Robin represents another
antithesis but in a way that's heroic as
opposed to like the villain being the
antithesis like what if what if Batman
was raised you know in a different
environment is Damian Wayne so I think
it'd be really interesting to have that
character in a movie like not the first
one I think well maybe the first one it
depends how deep they want to go but I
think I think a son of Batman like this
would be really interesting like live
action Choice yeah
with Aiden Gallagher that's wetcast
Aiden Gallagher where would I have seen
this lab he was uh the young gentleman
from Umbrella Academy uh okay okay
precocious little uh ax older than his
age he's the young one yeah the young
one the one that's like 30 going on
seven or whatever like that kid yeah I
think he'd be pretty exceptional just
just from the little brief glimpses I've
had I'm like yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah I can see that just gotta make him
get buffed buff child keep him in the
comics great night Nightwing man great
Nightwing introduction great Nightwing
use yeah I love that I love the way they
Incorporated Nightwing here no
post-credits scene nothing we found out
in real time because they're like we
should put Atlantis next we should
probably use it we should get back on
we've LED people to expect people wanted
more Batman we threw it in let's get
back to the throne of Atlantis
absolutely uh so what do you think I
enjoyed this man it was fun this was
really fun this was a character like
Damian Wayne is a character I'm aware of
and have seen in
you know limited takes on I haven't
really got a ton of like I know more
Robins than I do know uh Damien Wayans
but I thought this was a cool story and
I liked the way that they built the
character because at first Damien is a
bit frustrating he's he's a very
frustrated character but not in the way
you know like that it's easy to make
that off-putting or it's easy to make it
uh such that you can't come back and and
regain the you know affection for the
character once the growth happens and
here I appreciated that yeah there's
still tons more growth to to to occur
for Damien and between him and Bruce but
I like the little ways in which you can
tell like okay Damien is sort of coming
around to uh Bruce's way of doing things
and is at least you know like inclined
to listen a little bit because he is out
of his element even though he has you
know a an Elite Training background and
all that other stuff it's not the only
thing that matters yeah so yeah I really
like the way that they uh drove their
relationship and used other characters
like Alfred and Nightwing to bring some
humor out and to show that like yeah
everybody is kind of dabbing a deal with
this kid right now and we are kind of
along for the ride with them you can see
that we want to see things work out with
Batman and all that but uh but yeah what
do you think so I like the paternal
element you get from like the reason I
like Damian Wayne in the comics is it
allows Bruce to be a different person
and like we didn't get a lot of that but
the moments we had were great like the
the fair moment like the flashback
versus like I like that the Damian Wayne
had Bruce Wayne's hairline so like when
you saw him as a flashback you see that
like he looks just like you master Wayne
like I really like the paternal element
um because you know Robin's all were
always kind of like surrogate sons of
Batman and I was worried about the
character uh when I heard about him I
was like really just gonna make it
because it I thought it would undermine
I I think um
adoption is super important and I think
that uh the way we perceive family is
super important I think that like
families not just blood like I think
what you choose to do around people you
love makes them family so I was worried
that him having a blood son would
undermine the other Robins sure like
then they'd like lean too far and be
like well he's got Sons like why are we
making a son why is it that what a
redundancy yeah and then like the way it
then makes it about Talia and the league
is more interesting because of that
connection so I don't feel like it
undermines you know Tim or or dick or
Stephanie Brown or any of the other
Robin's uh you know uh that we currently
have but it does add another element to
his sons because there's like one son
that's got a different connection that's
fun yeah so I I like it actually I think
it's enhanced the bat family and it was
nice to see because because you know
having under the Red Hood uh uh in mind
uh you know I feel like Damien the story
could easily kind of Teeter on that
territory because so much of the
argument there is about you know not
going too far not having the Killer
Instinct there's all that competition
between them
um but here I thought that they did
nicely to not make it too much like that
despite the similarities and two I like
that yeah you have Batman in a position
to while he's doing his Batman thing
having to be more concerned like a
father would be and then having uh these
at least hints at you know the The Backs
round with him and Talia and stuff like
that at least having her like as as much
as I was a little taken aback by her
like again just like cat suit you know
like presents hey Batman yeah I'm not
quite used to catch it sometimes but
it's not like all tits like that's they
really well that's really like she's not
very well protected frankly as far as
violence goes she's exposed yeah yeah I
feel like in certain ways and again
that's also a character who I haven't
seen a million takes on their other
Batman characters I'm more familiar with
but in that in that opening battle she
did kind of feel like a Catwoman
character her nimbleness the agility
like a lot of those things yeah and the
and the sultriness that she proceeds
with you know alongside her great sense
of purpose you know all that I do like
uh that speaking of like Talia and
multiple characters that this was able
to balance you know Killer Croc uh
Man-Bat uh Natalia and Ross race
relationships man bad showed up like
there's a lot it's juggling Deathstroke
didn't feel shortchanged for having
other you know villains in it like
Deathstroke still got his time really
read this how it in the comics is
Deathstroke a character that gets used
and called upon a lot because from
watching the movies and in these
animated movies especially it seems like
Deathstroke it gets a lot at screen time
he's pretty prevalent like he's kind of
the go-to Assassin like he's he's very
much like the guy but on the Marvel side
I see Taskmaster as his equivalent and
Taskmaster is not used quite as much
like like he's used a lot and I think
that's why people were bummed with black
widow's choice to make it not a power
but make it something like technological
so I like that Deathstroke uh is a
character that seems to get like he
doesn't get killed like and I feel like
that's important like he he can't always
come back so I assume he doesn't we
didn't see a body
um but also he's not daddy's Taskmaster
yeah but I mean you see this problem uh
he's Deathstroke but I do think
Deathstroke is going to be a
foundational part of the new DC Universe
as well because I feel like all those
characters we almost got like are the
ones that were just set up like
mangiliano like playing them like we're
gonna see them get to flourish because
Deathstroke is pretty prevalent yeah
okay cool but yeah I dug this I think uh
they juggled a lot uh I think they told
the story well uh I I for some reason
like at the beginning I said like I
don't know what story this is going to
be like as soon as I was confirmed it
was Damian Wayne which I should have
assumed uh like I I didn't know if it
was going to be more of the vague Robin
element I also don't remember how
recently Damien was introduced before
this animated I think he's like 2000 10
but I don't know for sure that was gonna
be my next question is how recent of a
character because the robins seemed to I
mean you know Robin Dick goes back like
way far and then you know you have the
other Robins who I associate as being at
least around for a good while now and
Damien strikes me as the most recent
he's definitely the most recent of the
core Robins like there's alternate
universes and all that stuff but like I
mean Jim starlin's the one that wrote
Robin getting killed and I think that
was in the late 70s early 80s so like
you know with the vote with the vote the
vote that's now 40 years ago okay which
is crazy to think about yeah man that's
bananas and it's only going to get
crazier the further along we trudge down
the timeline yeah I mean this this
movie's almost 10 years old 2014 was
like 10 years ago I haunts me that is a
terrifying statistic don't love the 2014
feels like the future like it doesn't
even feel past like when I say 2014 like
that's coming up yeah
any time now anything past 2010 does
still feel like it's somehow kind of the
future teen after 20 it's like that's
yeah crazy 2004 sounds dated but 2014
does not it's almost a decade since
2014. yeah we are approaching Blade
Runner 2049 rapidly but yeah I dug this
uh I'm excited for more um of this
universe I did feel like this was more
it's interesting because Flashpoint
apparently starts this and then Justice
League Ward didn't feel connected to
Flashpoint now and I understand it
starts a Multiverse but this then felt
like the standard Universe of Batman
from the comic book
and Justice League War felt like an
alternate universe so I feel like we've
got three different universes so far yes
I'm like do you feel the same I do I'm
very fascinated to see how these line up
and how they build upon each other
because this
it's funny this feels more totally akin
to what we saw with like under the Red
Hood right which is not attached to any
of this yeah yeah and so this did a nice
job of at least like you have the Jason
O'Meara Batman back so you have that
piece of connective tissue and this
story is much more contained and
personal so it breathes in a different
way that I uh appreciated but yeah
looking at the progression thus far it
has felt
I guess somewhat disjointed this doesn't
feel quite as disjointed as Justice
League War only because it is actually
at least taking the one character from
that and or Flashpoint I should say
um but and it feels like the culture
this one was the Jason O'Mara I feel
like that may have been flash boy damn
we gotta do our that's the thing let me
go back because it's hard to tell why
they're in this order because yeah so
far and that's what's exciting is
apparently there's 49 of these but like
how do they connect and what is that
relation we're gonna find out in real
time because this doesn't feel like a
sequel to war or that it sets up Throne
of Atlantis and I get that there's like
a Justice League through line and then
there's side missions but I'm just confu
I'm excited yeah excited to see how it
connects yeah this was fun glad we're
doing these uh if you want us to do more
of these like comment you're probably
already subscribed if you're not get on
it hit that notification Bell we can
only keep doing these people keep
watching them because otherwise it's
weird to tape it otherwise we're just
gonna watch them without you guys we'll
just watch this cuddle on the couch and
snuggle up and watch private and cast
many singers as the players in the in
the DC Universe and that you won't get
on on these watch along so please do
comment share show your friends uh and
if you want to watch it sync to sync one
to end Slide the line join a patreon and
see it all the way through with this all
synced up um this uh this has been fun
we're gonna we're gonna do Justice
League Throne of Atlantis next which is
the post-credits scene of the last movie
it's gonna be good next to find out what
Aquaman was up to what was he doing just
swimming talking to fish where was he
direct this this is all happened it was
a lot of water he was talking another
shark he sent that shark do you set the
Sharks he's like yo get that man I got
you yeah yeah yeah Jason Momoa going
yeah
my man it bites him yeah yeah it's gonna
be good it's gonna be good all right
appreciate you thank you for being here
thank you for watching uh let us know
what your favorite of these animated
movies are let us know what you thought
of this one let us know if we're wrong
about what predictions are to come but
don't spoil anything because I'm very
curious how 49 movies connect that are
so far doing this at us all right we'll
see you soon reject Nation much love
foreign